Bulgaria in Croatia today to commit a
step in their journey to join the hero
the two countries are now participating
in the banking Union and the Exchange
Rate Mechanism the anti chamber of our
single currency our decision to include
the Bulgarian labs in the Croatian Kuna
in the mechanism takes account the
measures the two governments have taken
and their future commitments successful
participation in erm - for at least the
next two years would see Bulgaria in
Croatia fulfilling one of the four
convergence criteria for joining the
euro I could not think of a better
decision to announce at the end of my
mandate more than ever our single
currency the currency of the union is
living up to its promise of being a
protective shield for our economies and
an engine of prosperity Bulgarian
Croatian applications are a sign of
confidence in our decision is a show of
inclusiveness for this I am confident
others will follow their lead to join
the euro in the future
[Music]